I'm loving this blue velvet number here
thank you I just want it to be cozy it's
gonna be such a fun one tonight we have
a seventh heaven reunion happening you
Jessica Beale and Lance Bass is also
gonna be here it's literally like uh
it's like a high school reunion for all
of us like I mean I just it's it's
amazing when the gang gets all back
together I mean what is it like uh you
know Jesse and I see each other often
because obviously like she's my bestie
she's my ride or die she is my ride or
die so uh you know but it's always fun
Lucy Camden uh let's unpack some of this
trauma of yours I think it was an
alcoholic my sister was a financial
energy boosters and my brother had a
baggy pants face were you surprised at
how much the internet loved your Tick
Tock about the Wild storylines on
Seventh Heaven everyone was obsessed
well you know what's funny is I saw that
and I was like Hey I want in on the fun
like I want to have some fun and I mean
it's it's very funny because the reality
is I I don't remember a lot about so
like
I have to like re-watch it myself
because I don't it was my life so I
don't remember everything I mean I think
the fans remember more than I do what do
you remember just about that chapter of
your life I just remember like you know
the the family like I remember like my
battles with Jess and I remember like us
that Sisterhood that we created like
most of my memories and most of my
Fondest Memories Are teamed up with her
and look at this decades later you two
are still thick as see and we've got our
babies together and so yeah what do you
remember when it comes to the fashion
because of course Cruel Summer is all
the Nostalgia I mean this is 2001
Jessica Biel the crimp tear we've got
the low rise pants the Cami and the yeah
it was she thought it was cool you know
there's a lot of looks we're starting to
see all the trends come back man some
Trends should just stay dead stay in the
bath yes I want to go back to the tig
talk really quick though because I'm
curious did any other cast members react
to it to you do you guys have a group
text that you share things like that in
no not really
um so I don't know what anybody thought
about I just thought it was fun I
reached out to Rob myself and I was like
hey uh this is fun can I can we do this
and he's like I'm gonna be in La I'm
like perfect let's do it
and we it was it was it was a blast I
don't even know if Jess saw it but um
it you know it was just fun all these
decades later y'all are still sharing
the content we want oh yeah
what can we say as someone who grew up
on 7th Heaven thank you for all of the
art you've you've given us through the
years and I'm so glad to see two amazing
women sticking together through all the
years and that female friendship in
Hollywood I mean that speaks volume I
will do anything for her absolutely
[Music]
thank you